c'est une annonce qui a fait sourire la
semaine dernière celle du premier
ministre jean castex qui avait déclaré à
la télévision que les stations de ski
allait rouvrir mais pas les remontées
mécaniques ils sont pas loisible à tous
de se rendre dans les stations
simplement toutes les remontées
mécaniques seront fermés une absurdité
qui avait conduit de nombreux amateurs
de ski à organiser des vacances dans des
stations à l'étranger dans des pays qui
eux ou vers les stations et les remonter
et pour éviter un afflux de touristes
trop important et la concurrence
déloyale avec nos stations de ski
françaises
emmanuel macron avait prévenu que des
mesures seraient prises oui nous aurons
des mesures restrictives et dissuasif
des propos qui a confirmé ce matin jean
castex
chez bourdin on énumérons des règles pas
forcément très clair qu'on fera des
contrôles aléatoires à la frontière mes
vacances je les passerai la conclusion à
tirer mais je sais que je vais pas un
juif
bref des tests seront réalisés d
isolement prévu mais surtout une amende
pour tous ceux qui tenteraient de se
rendre en suisse en espagne ou en
autriche pour aller skier alors selon
vous faut-il mettre des amendes aux
français qui vont faire du ski à
l'étranger d'accord
pas d
il ya cet hiver ils vont faire du gofle
pour passer d'esquisser les rues de
funchal hier les gars ils m'ont caché
mes skis dans sous le toit sous les eaux
ou quazar est un truc de fou ça y est tu
t'es fait gauler j'ai pris 15 ans ils
m'ont chopé un butin avec un surf où
j'ai pris 15 piges
tu vois ça tombe donc imaginé tes sur
les pistes ça veut dire sur les pistes
alors gare à vous si vous arrivez à
passer vous êtes en espagne en train de
ski et gentiment ce qu'on peut skier en
espagne un mois j'ai skié sur la costa
del sol était tranquillement en train ce
qui y est là y'a un mec de perros cyril
ça va bien car ils vont envoyer méga
soirée pizza del arte tranquillement en
suisse l'atari st jean de matha touquet
en garde on te voit en train de parler
français sur un tire-fesses je peux te
dire que tu vas prendre plein la gueule
un vrai mon nom l'aberration sait même
pas sur les pistes c'est quand tu vas
rentrer apparemment quand tu vas rentrer
de suisse à la frontière et vont ils
vont ils vont fouiller ta voiture pour
savoir si tu as été inscrits ou pemex et
alors ils ont voulu des classes pour
ceux qui vont passer les flèches
d'argent les chamois d'or cachés du côté
du pétrole parce que tu veux ça veut
dire qu'il va enfin ils vont donner du
travail à la police pour savoir qui
était ce qui est qui n'a pas été ce
qu'il a à dire tu peux aller pas un peu
près que j'ai un flagrant délit de
personnes en mono rien
sur les maréchaux ça veut dire faire
courir après 130 cymbales encore parce
que c'est ça pour courir après 135 ma
sortie peut aller au mexique tu peux
aller en tunisie
tu peux aller au maroc tu connais
partout dans le monde rires si vous
trouvez ci gardent bien sûr si vous avez
un prénom français là bas vous appelez
pépito ne connaissez pas la france parce
que je vous le dise avatar a contrôlé
dans tous les chantiers ça va être ça
revient d'autres pays on se marre ça
revient d'autres pays sans contrôle tu
arrives à l'aéroport tu reviens tu as
pas de contrôle par email à gérard
aubert de suisse taille fessiers bon
voilà scission du récent est ce qu'il a
dit à castex ceux qui reviennent de
suisse alors vous le dit ceux qui
reviennent de suite vaut mieux ramener
des mallettes de zaïko des filles alors
mais je vous le dis et vous risquez moi
le gars tu vas année des scribes à s'en
prendre plein la gueule
et puisque j'aime pas dans son
intervention pour finir il ya vraiment
vraiment dans son intervention un côté
dictature qu'est ce que vous faites mais
vous restez là vous vous taisez vous
allez bosser puis vous fermez votre
gueule c'est un peu entre les lignes non
non moi je le dis il m'a dit s'il vous
plaît alors on à l'ars présentatrice
présentant et ben oui parce que je pense
qu'il faut effectivement c'est paris les
tricks sur mes joues biais d'e on et
dont on est dans le podium de la cus est
partitionné obligé oublié de lancer ma
gueule c'est parti battus et d'adopter
mercy nourdine heureusement que tu es là
tu sais on a toujours besoin de
quelqu'un d'autre sud soit tu sais pas
il faut effectivement des restrictions
nécessaires des tests et l'isolément à 7
jours après vous isoler ou non être
après les skis à l'étranger pourquoi pas
sur wii où les français en suisse en
autriche puisque c'est tout vert est
aussi en espagne
sauf que le nombre de contaminations est
en ce moment est en moyenne trois fois
plus élevé donc ils vont aller là bas
ils vont se faire contaminer et ils vont
revenir en france
donc ce serait à rennes on va revenir en
france la gueule on sacrifier tous nos
efforts alors qu'en ce moment ça se
passe beaucoup mieux changer ça marche
ce serait dommage de sacs remplis et
tous nos efforts c'est au p 3 km des
amendes aux français qui ont perdu
jusqu'à l'étranger
nicolas pernikoff vous dites oui un
grand oui à montbard grand oui à manger
il faut aller il faut il faut être
logique ses terres c'est là qu'une
concurrence déloyale crt jambon ceux qui
ont les moyens parce que l'art il parle
de la suisse et tout mais il faut y
aller en suisse est la suisse se
disputent la remontée face à elle
tu fais réduisant la journée tu en as
pour 3000 euros cookshire et l'hôtel ces
six mois de salaire non mais blague à
part si je peux vous donner un conseil
les points que vous allez dans un hôtel
en suisse ne prenait pas la pension la
demi pension
mais son lit c'est le seul droitier
dégénère 5000 euros par jour ma part
c'est de la concurrence déloyale donc
c'est normal qu'ils aient qu'il aille
jusqu'au bout de son truck series
connaître aux gens que s'ils avaient une
barre devant maxime ses 5000 moulin est
ouvert
pourquoi il voulait fermer pour moi à
carrefour ils ont droit de vendre des
livres à leclerc jean morange déloyale
alors on ferme
c'est ça qui me l'a foutu la merde parce
qu on est tout le temps genou de loi si
la suisse elle est ouverte harmonisons
là c'est vrai
fermé ou l'espagne s'est fermé on est
vraiment européen
ou alors c'est un super chevron nous
tâchons comme on a ouvert en suisse et
dans les supermarchés vous croyez qu'il
ya c'est moins risqué dans d'une façon
ce qui peut pas tout ça est et touchant
la france prend souvent exemple sur ses
voisins et la haine ne le fait pas en
fait c'est une après crise enfin où
c'est une crise une crise qui n'est pas
gérable qui n'est pas géré et le porho
castex je pense qu'on va le retenir en
tant que premier ministre qui aura
ouvert les stations de ski sont les
remonter oui les gars mais dont la
saillie dans la presse la magnifique
oui alors effet non vous skiez encore
vous et vous tu m'avais remis sur les
skis j'ai fait de la compétition peu de
ce qu'ils avaient tout à rennes on a des
photos kong le contraire de ce qui va
bien pour me taquiner ça m'a plu parce
que je skie bien d'accord de la
nécessité de faire l'europe parce qu'il
ya deux mois c'est les suisses qui
interdisent la conforter cette venez
remplies et qu'il émettait en 40 m6
avait fraudé donc là déjà ça ne tiennent
pas bien ce matin et l'europe se tenir
que là franchement et tirent chacun dans
son coin et en revanche et c'était quoi
le règlement dormez vous
on avait des sentiments faut quand même
rappeler il faut encore à pékin juste
français sur 10 qui part ou alain m'a
bien sûr il faut pas ces normes et là
dessus avec vous avant je suis tout
faire vous dire contre cette décision
que je trouve aberrante
alors je sais bien que les hôpitaux sont
totalement engorgés bah oui et que c'est
ça qu'on essaie de faire attention et
que justement lutte aussi contre la la
la quid le vous avez des goûts
on se perd de ses trois points des
drômois gd captain igloo l'ag du poisson
là sans rigoler mais comme arthur façade
mais pas au wimax
elle était voix j'ai fait des dégâts
il mangeait du poisson des mecs là pour
la mémoire c'est trop wyss 35% non à a
fait des dons à 65% voilà oui vous dira
tout moi je sais qui est en plein paris
a trouvé la solution
les shérifs